what I tell young girl about strength
that it definitely comes from within
Selena Gomez opening up about what makes
her strong strong girl is something I
try to be every single day but it's so
hard it's so hard for me
I feel best when my mind is right and my
body is right
it is not weak to be vulnerable or to
share what's on your heart a real
strength is vulnerability honesty and
compassion the singer got candid on the
set of her new puma campaign shoot I get
as far as a lot of women I love Lee and
get this the ad star a few of her
favorite women all my friends are a part
of the shoot and all have different body
types and it's just beautiful to see
them wear things that make them feel
good I don't know what I would be
without my friends they've saved my life
they've been there for me through the
thick and thin of all while the 26 year
old is feeling strong these days she
admits she has her insecurities just
like any other girl I always like to
have some quality where I bring out the
best and a girl cuz I was that girl I
mean I feel insecure all the time I can
awkward it's something where I feel like
I can connect to them Selena also opened
up to l.com on the set of the shoot
revealing the importance of finding
strength from within quote I think it's
important for girls to know the strength
in everything their identity and their
soul lies within themselves and too much
today you give that away so easily from
social media to school or relationships
and I think it's important I want to
remind girls that they're perfectly
strong the way they are I'm really big
on vulnerability selena opened up to ET
about the misconceptions of being strong
in 2017 I think people are really scared
to be honest with themselves and
strength is looked upon as
oh I'm strong I don't need any
I can handle everything and that's just
not the truth and I think kids
especially with social media sometimes
they just feel a little claustrophobic
and I don't think their voice is
actually being heard and I think that's
the message I want I want people to know
that every every single life is valuable
that their voice can be heard and other
people who are willing to be there for
them
[Music]